Là on est d'accord c'est pas possible, ça
marche pas du tout. On va changer ça de
suite. C'est quand même vachement mieux là on
est bien d'accord je vous montre comment
j'ai fait juste après l'intro et salut à
tous les amis c'est françois pour la
chaîne explique moi encore aujourd'hui
on va parler d'éclairage parce que j'ai
passé des jours et des jours et des
jours à batailler pour avoir le meilleur
éclairage possible celui que je
préférais que trouver le plus joli et
j'ai trouvé sympa de vous partager en
fait ce que j'ai fait mes recherches les
tests que j'ai fait le matériel que
j'utilise et on va en parler tout de
suite
alors on ne dira jamais assez
l'éclairage c'est super important c'est
indispensable
vous avez vu au début en fait c'est tout
noir mais bon j'aurais pu monter un
petit peu la sensibilité de mon capteur
mais j'aurais eu une image super dégradé
rien que la nécessité de la lumière pour
avoir une image de qualité
c'est indispensable grosso modo
plusieurs lumières mieux c'est un même
si il ya des histoires de filtrage des
tout ça on en a parlé ici voilà il faut
il faut absolument de la lumière sinon
l'image est dégueulasse mais au-delà de
cette nécessité d'avoir une quantité de
lumière suffisante pour avoir une image
de qualité
on va pouvoir aussi travaillé sur des
aspects esthétiques et pour vous
expliquer comment j'ai choisi mes
lumières et comment je les ai agencé et
je vais vous expliquer ce que je voulais
en fait les faits que je voulais
produire alors première chose je voulais
que le sujet se détache du fonds et le
sujet c'est bibi
c'est pas une histoire d'égocentrisme
c'est juste histoire d'avoir l'air à peu
près correct devant la caméra
et si vous êtes un habitué de la chaîne
vous savez que avant je shootais sur le
cannon que maintenant je suis sûre sony
et sur les précédentes vidéos je n'avais
aucune difficulté à séparer le sujet du
fond plus que j'avais mes objectifs qui
ouvrait très grand f 2,8
donc comme vous pouvez voir sur ces
extraits j'avais un super flou
d'arrière-plan due à l'ouverture de
l'objectif
sauf qu'au passage chez sony et ben les
objectifs coûtant un bras j'ai pas pu
prendre des objectifs qui n'ouvrait
aussi grand
j'ai des trucs qui ouvre moins grand
donc j'ai moins de flou d'arrière-plan
et il a fallu que je trouve une solution
et justement la solution ça a été
d'utiliser la lumière puisque on peut
détacher le sujet grâce au flou
d'arrière plan mais on peut aussi
travailler sur l'éclairage
donc ça c'est le premier point un sujet
bien détaché du fonds pour que ça soit
plus joli plus contrastée et justement
en parlant de contraste je voulais aussi
pouvoir avoir des ombres notamment
celles qui sont sur le visage sur le
côté que je trouve super jolie en
l'occurrence le petit triangle qui se
trouvent ici qui est généralement très
utilisé en photo en interview bref quand
on a quelqu'un qui parle ça un petit
côté esthétique qu'il faut viser donc si
vous avez un truc à chercher c'est le
petit triangle clair sur ce côté du
visage
voilà pour les effets que je recherchais
maintenant on va voir avec quel matos on
peut les obtenir
alors vous avez pu voir si vous êtes
abonnés à la chaîne dans les autres
vidéos je fais souvent plaint décès en
terme de fond en terme de
hier j'ai rarement deux fois la même
chose ça m'a un petit peu saoulé donc
j'ai voulu mettre un point final à cette
recherche de lumière et trouver la
config ultime donc au départ au tout
départ j'utilisais de la lumière
naturelle j'ai essayé les sauf box et
j'en suis venu à me dire que les soldes
box est quand même vachement plus simple
parce que la lumière naturelle souvent
quand je tourne elle varie donc j'ai
tout fermé je suis dans le noir éclairé
uniquement avec des naturel pour
l'éclairage artificiel j'ai longtemps
utilisé des soldes box entrée de gamme
de chez amazon qui sont ma foi c'est
correct mais un petit peu fragile
aujourd'hui j'utilise des sauces boxe à
l'aide de chez api tueur je mets tous
les liens en inscription bien sûr qu'ils
sont un petit peu plus cher mais l'
avantage des led c'est que c'est quand
même un peu moins fragile c'est
vachement plus petits c'est ça passe par
tous et discret ça rentre dans un sac
c'est vraiment très sympa et ses sauces
boxe a pu tuer en bas j'en utilise de
ces deux sauf boxe ce sont mes lumières
principal mais j'utilise également des
lumières de déco 1 pour donner un petit
peu plus de couleurs et agrémenter un
petit peu plus le fond de manière
lumineuse
alors ici j'utilise une philippe une ue
dont je vous mets aussi le lien en
descriptions 6-4 bien c'est qu'on peut
changer la couleur la réaction de
téléphones portables se paramétrer des
scènes etc
celles qui se trouvent sur le personnel
ici c'est aussi une philips view mais
celle ci l epa mobil 1 allée directement
approché que c'est une ampoule led aussi
qui peut changer de couleur mais là pour
le coup je voulais quelque chose d'assez
neutre donc elle est en blanc puis après
selon les envies j'ai des petites lampes
de déco comme ici des trucs à pas cher
pareil sur amazon ou des petites led par
endroits ça dépend un petit peu de ce
que j'ai envie de faire mais là pour le
coup on n'est vraiment pas sûr de
l'éclairage principal c'est du plus
c'est vraiment le petit bonus la petite
cerise sur le gâteau c'est vraiment
d'éléments de décoration
moi je sais ce que vous vous dites
d'infini nous raconter un petit peu ta
life là comme ça tu nous dit mme tu les
as place et élan pourra voir cette
lumière sublime superbe on voit toit des
fleurs françois et parce qu'on si on
place ses soldes boxe
son éclairage n'importe comment bas le
résultat peut être tout aussi
dégueulasse que si on en avait pas donc
je vais vous expliquez moi comment je
place les miennes sachant qu'il ya plein
de configuration possible que ça c'est
celle que j'ai trouvé sympa que j'ai
trouvé la plus jolie et qui rend le
mieux dans la pièce sachant que
l'appartement
il est ultra mal foutu et j'ai pas
beaucoup de profondeur de changer un peu
tous dans la même pièce
sachant que tout le bordel de
l'appartement et de l'autre côté ça
allait ranger comme ça ici mais la
bassée voilà pour placer ces lampes j'ai
utilisé une règle d'éclairage en trois
points
j'ai un petit peu modifié puisque
j'utilise que deux lampes la première
sauf beau se trouve ici à peu près à 45
degrés par rapport à mon visage
elle est très près un haut niveau
quasiment de l'appareil qui est aussi
assez près de l'appareil et elle va me
servir de qu'il ait ça veut dire que
c'est l'éclairage principal de mon face
caméra le fait qu'elle soit 45 degrés et
pas juste en face à bah ça me permet
d'avoir justement ces ombres sur le côté
du visage et le fameux petit triangle
dont je vous parlais juste avant ce qui
va amener du contraste un petit peu sur
le visage et qui va aussi grandement
amélioré le teint de peau et ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que sur cette lampe la
j'utilise un diffuseur 1 c'est à dire un
petit bout de tissu accrochée sur la
langue parce que sinon la lumière serait
beaucoup trop dur donc avec le diffuseur
en adoucit la lumière et c'est quand
même beaucoup plus joli en fait ça évite
d'avoir des contrastes trop prononcée
alors au passage le diffuseur un futur à
60 balles avec des petites tiges en
plastoc qui ont pété la première fois
que je les ai sortis ça fout grave les
boules vraiment grave les boules c'est
60 balles pour un petit bout de tissu
quatre tiges en plastique et non c'est
c'est abusé la culture là dessus vous
avez marre des bons jeunes et bricolé
j'ai réussi à m'en sortir mais mais fait
chier quoi la deuxième lumière elle est
tout simplement cachée si je l'avais
mise de ce côté là j'aurais
dézinguer tout mes ombres que je
cherchais mon contraste avec tout
simplement derrière moi là alors
pourquoi j'ai mis cette lumière derrière
moi c'est pour faire ce qu'on appelle
une backelite c'est-à-dire un éclairage
par l'arrière ici on travaille
directement sur ce que je disais au
départ c'est à dire avoir un sujet qui
se détache du fonds pas par un fou mais
par la lumière parce que si vous
observez bien justement le côté un peu
sombres de mon visage
ici il va trancher avec l'arrière plan
qui est éclairée et ceci j'éclaire pas à
l'arrière-plan ça donne un truc comme ça
alors le visage est toujours reculer
correctement n'y a pas de souci mais le
problème c'est qu'ils se détachent
beaucoup moins du fond puisque le fonds
est sombre et que cette partie sombre de
mon visage elles se font un petit peu
dans l'ariège peur comme ça c'est
beaucoup mieux alors j'aurais pu la
diriger directement dans mon dos pour
avoir un petit halo autour du visage
j'ai pas trouvé ça super judicieux je
préfère la diriger vers le mur derrière
qui est blanc qui joue le rôle de
diffuseur pour le coup puisque j'en ai
pas sur 7/7 l'emploi et qui va permettre
de réfléchir la lumière du panneau
l'aide un peu partout dans la pièce et
ris parce qu'un mur blanc ça peut servir
de réflecteurs diffuseur de lumière ne
faut pas hésiter aussi à éclairer sur un
mur blanc sur quelque chose de blanc qui
va permettre d'adoucir la lumière ça
c'est vachement important pas une
lumière trop dur hein sinon ça ça va
casser un petit peu tous les faits du
truc adouci son le truc c'est non pas
plus compliqué que ça il n'y a pas
besoin de trois lumières j'aurais pu
aussi utiliser un réflecteur sur ce côté
là pour peut-être un vrai un petit peu
d'ombré mais j'aime vraiment beaucoup le
côté contraste et qu'on peut avoir avec
cette disposition là il n'y a pas
forcément besoin de de lumière non plus
avec une si elle est suffisamment grande
ça peut être sympa il suffira juste
peut-être d'être moins loin du fond ça
pourra servir d'éclairage principal est
quasiment totale de la scène mais c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir quand même
une backelite même s'il est un petit peu
bricolé pour détacher le sujet qui en
face mais j'ai envie de dire si vous
deviez on n'utilisait que deux
là qu'il ait hélas backelite c'est quand
même le plus important le gros avantage
d'avoir une config comme ça c'est qu'on
peut la reproduire alors pour l'instant
je n'ai pas la chance de pouvoir laisser
mon matos il faut que je le monte on le
démonte à chaque fois ça va probablement
changer mais le truc cool c'est qu'on va
pouvoir avoir le même type d'image sur
chaque vidéo en plaçant la lumière au
même endroit en gardant les mêmes
réglages par rapport à la lumière
naturelle qui elle va varier en fait en
fonction de la météo en fonction du
moment de la journée si vous tournez à
10 heures le matin si vous tournez à 17
heures le soir la lumière est pas du
tout la même si on veut quelque chose de
consistant il va falloir tourner au même
horaire avec des conditions météo
relativement similaires ça devient quand
même un petit peu compliqué davantage de
ses lumières artificielles c'est qu'on
va pouvoir le reproduire à l'infini dans
des conditions qui vont être quasi
similaire à chaque fois donc ça vaut
quand même un petit peu le coup de se
faire chier moi j'ai passé deux bonnes
journées et pour le coup on va gagner
beaucoup de temps pour la suite oui oui
mais voilà les amis c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura plu qu'elle vous aura aidé si
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à mettre le
traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
la partager à vos amis n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner si c'est pas déjà le cas un
ca soutient la chaîne et ça fait
vachement plaisir et puis moi je vous
dis comme d'habitude rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
oui je sais ça fait plus de deux
semaines que j'ai pas sorti de vidéos et
en même temps j'ai envie de dire
j'emmerde l'algorithme de youtube parce
que bah je sais que vous aimez les
vidéos de qualité alors je prends le
temps de vous faire des vidéos de
qualité parce que vous le valez bien
bientôt pub l'oréal ça